[Music]
hey what's up I'm kbhd here and every
year like clockwork around the second
week of September assuming no pandemic
related delays we expect the new iPhone
to come out or iPhones since now it's a
whole lineup of phones and last year was
the biggest iPhone lineup ever unveiled
all at once we got four different models
and we fully expect again this year to
see four new models and the evolving
rumors about them have been making
headlines for the past couple months as
always real quick first though we have
finally launched that secret second
channel it's the studio Channel and it's
up the first video that just dropped
today is now live it's a studio tour
which a lot of you guys have been asking
about and now you can finally see the
finished space you can meet the team and
you can head over there and subscribe to
see a lot more stuff like behind the
scenes and all the sort of things you've
been asking that we don't quite get a
chance to put on the main channel it's
all over there if you subscribe soon
hopefully you can be one of the first
hundred thousand in in the first week
it's one of our goals that would be nice
okay so I've got four of the new models
of the iPhone 13 expected this year and
they map right alongside last year 13
mini the 13 the 13 Pro and the 13 Pro
Max I'm predicting this is going to be a
pretty short video because they are so
similar also of course it doesn't
guarantee a whole lot but these are just
some of the things that we think we can
expect from the next iPhone these aren't
of course from Apple they're made around
the things we expect to see and so if
you want to build cases or accessories
for the iPhone that's what these sort of
models are built to be useful for so as
we've learned it's about to be August
and these phones in Real Life are
already pretty much Hardware locked
somewhere inside Apple's Spaceship
Campus right now as we approach fall for
launch but just so we're clear this is
all still technically speculation but
holding these models in the hand for the
first time it's pretty quickly evident
we're looking at pretty similar designs
right same shapes same sizes this of
course lines up with the the flat line
and everything from last year's iPhone
makes sense we've seen them stick with
one design for multiple years and this
is the 12's design the new stuff that we
can actually look at though are number
one
the port now a port is technically not a
new thing since we've always had ports
but there's been a rumor that's made the
rounds about Apple possibly getting rid
of the lightning port and not switching
to USBC but just going totally portless
completely wireless for everything on
all the new iPhones or maybe just the
pro phones but possibly across the whole
lineup and while I still think they're
aiming for that and I made a whole video
about why Apple's aiming for a portless
future these new models all of them do
have ports now to me that just says the
magsafe ecosystem is not quite ready to
pick up where lightning left off now
there was a big deal made about magsafe
it was the new charging standard the new
wireless charging on the back of the
iPhone slapping on there with magnets
and there are a bunch of really good
magsafe accessories out now there's
magsafe compatible cases there are
things that slap on the back of the
phone my favorite car mount is really
good the one moment makes I'll link that
one below I've been using it for a while
now but even Apple's first party
accessories are slowly starting to grow
out they just drop that hundred dollar
magsafe battery bank that attaches to
the back of the iPhone but it really
does feel a little early to just jump
straight to that and totally get rid of
the port it was already kind of a big
deal when Apple bumped up from 5 watts
to 20 watts of charging on the iPhone
magsafe only supports up to 15 watts
we're living in a world where there are
phones charging at 50 65 maybe soon 100
plus Watts wirelessly which is awesome
and this just isn't quite at the
flagship at the tier that I'd want it to
be so maybe they're waiting for better
wireless charging to to make the mag
safe transition easier but at this point
it feels too easy to go portless or too
early to go poreless so then the rest of
the phone pretty much lines up with the
iPhone 12s same speaker placement same
thickness and height across the lineup
then I did notice slightly lower button
placement actually which I like a lot
and feels best on the bigger phones but
this is actually only on the middle size
phones the 13 and the 13 Pro the buttons
are in the same place on the 13 Pro Max
and the 13 mini interestingly but then
one more big change is these cameras
which are somehow all bigger so the 13
and 13 mini here have dual cameras still
but they switch to this diagonal
orientation and then the 13 Pro and 13
Pro Max still have triple cameras but
look at the new size of these camera
modules they're bigger and they look
pretty similar at first but I actually
think we can read into these a little
bit more than them just being bigger so
here's my interpretation of this in the
13 and the 13 Mini
you've got these two dual cameras now
roughly the same size of overall module
they're a diagonal lineup now and the
lower right one is actually a bit larger
which to me would hopefully mean a
larger sensor back here which is nice
we've wanted larger sensors in iPhones
for a long time and they only did one
larger sensor on last year's iPhone the
Big 12 Pro Max but it's possible and we
see this all the time where the newest
stuff the best stuff from last year
Flagship trickles down in price so that
could be what we're seeing here with
bigger sensor now on the 13 pro and pro
Max though the big phones check this out
the whole camera bump is a larger
footprint but it's not because the
lenses are much bigger they're actually
just a bit more spread out and to me
this might not actually be bigger
sensors but it may be better
stabilization so you may remember last
year on that iPhone 12 Pro Max that was
the only one to feature Advanced sensor
shift stabilization and it was only on
the larger primary sensor this year it
looks like there may be more room to use
this more active precise censorship
stabilization on all of the sensors so
even if the sensor isn't bigger or if
it's a little bit bigger they can hold
it still for longer shutter speeds and
longer periods of time and that gets you
less noise in photos without the
drawbacks that come from huge sensors
and smartphones like super shallow depth
of field fringing so those are some
interesting things to look forward to
behind the new designs of some of these
cameras here now of course there's a
bunch of other stuff that these new
models or mock-ups will never tell us
like promotion that's one of the biggest
almost weirdly most interesting rumors
about these new phones because you think
by now where every other phone out there
has a higher fresh rate display the
iPhone being last up they've got to do
it we don't know that just from these
dummies but it may just be the Pro
Models or maybe across the lineup either
way I hope to see promotion but then
these models don't tell us specs or Ram
or anything like that we already know
what iOS 15 looks like that should
launch typically around the same time
the iPhone does and they also don't tell
us if the notch is the same size now but
there is one thing to notice which is if
you look closely on some of these models
you can see you know they've cut out
some smaller sensors underneath the
earpiece but they did move the earpiece
all the way up further up higher on the
top of the phone and I feel like that's
only something you would do if you're
sort of reorganizing or sort of just
compressing all of these pieces up here
in the face ID cluster to try to make a
smaller Notch so not getting rid of it
but at least giving you some of that
screen real estate back now that the
iPhone really just has one of the
biggest notches in any phone and has for
a couple years now then there are still
some rumors about them possibly bringing
an in-display fingerprint reader to
bring Touch ID back and maybe combine
that with face ID
as much as I would like to see it
personally I feel like this one's less
likely I could see them just totally
ignoring fingerprint sensors and
sticking with face ID but that's it
that's really all we get from these sort
of models when they come out every year
we don't even know if it's going to be
called the iPhone 13. it could be 12s
for all we know although that's pretty
unlikely because there was no 11s it
seems like they're just going just
straight with the plus one number from
here on out but yeah what do you think
is uh is this upgrade I'm just I'm
holding the the model of the pro Max
right now is 120 hertz display and
possibly some better cameras on the back
enough
to get you to upgrade and I guess that's
a bit of a weird question because most
people with last year's phone shouldn't
be upgrading anyway but on older phones
even to tell the difference if some of
these uh smaller models like the mini
the 13 mini or the 13 are really just a
slight camera Improvement and some
bumped specs feels like almost the same
phone but I'm curious what you guys
think of what you've seen from these
models either way that's been it thanks
for watching and definitely make sure to
check out the studio Channel really
excited about its launching and I'll see
you guys over there all right catch you
later peace
foreign